So, before we begin,
I just want to make
sure you guys all remember
about the quiz on Friday.
So the quiz is going to
be in Walker at 2 pm.
Everybody goes to Walker.
The quiz is open book.
You can bring your own notes.
You can bring a class notes,
bring the readings from class;
you can bring your calculator.
But please don't bring any
computers, phones, PDAs,
things like that.
So make sure you have all
your stuff printed out
before you show up if you've
been taking notes on a laptop.
OK, so what we're going to
do today is just quickly,
well, we're going to do an
introduction to networking.
But quickly I just
want to finish
the topic of caching
that we began,
that sort of introduced at
the very end of the lecture
last time.
So, if you guys
remember, we were
talking about our pipeline
WebServer system that
consisted of these three stages:
a networking stage connected up
to our HTML stage connected
up to our disk stage.
OK, and we did a
little performance
analysis of the system.
We looked at what the cost
of each of these stages
is, what sort of throughput of
each one of these stages is.
We said that as long as we
split this networking module up
into ten submodules, we can get
the throughput of this thing
to be about 100
requests per second.
We said the latency
of this was 1 ms.
So that means it can process a
thousand requests per second.
We said the latency
of the disk was 10 ms.
So that means it
can also process
100 requests per second.
And we said, remember, that when
we are looking at a pipeline,
the sort of throughput
of the entire pipeline
is going to be
bottlenecked by the slowest
stage in the system.
And so if we look
at this, we see
that these two stages
are both running
at 100 requests per second.
But we have a very simple way of
making this first network stage
be able to process more
requests per second,
right, because we
simply can replicate
the number of threads
that are sending
data out over the network.
So, for example, if we went from
ten nodes here to 100 nodes,
we could increase the
throughput of this stage
to 1,000 requests
per second, which
means that now the bottleneck
stage that we have is simply
the disk stage.
So the question is,
is there something
we can do to increase the
throughput of the disk stage?
If you think about
it, at first it
may seem like, well,
there's probably
no way that we can do anything
because the disk takes 10 ms,
you know, every page
takes 10 ms to read in.
So what are we going
to do about that?
And there's a very
sort of standard answer
to that that you guys
have all seen before,
and that answer is caching.
OK so the simple
idea is that we're
going to take this IO
stage, or this disk stage,
with this disk
that runs at 10 ms.
What I've shown here
is a very simple piece
of pseudo code that
might correspond
to what this sort
of read or the get
page ID function for
this IO stage does.
It simply calls
some read function
that reads page ID off the
disk and then returns the page.
If we add a cache
to this system,
suppose we have
an in memory cache
that can retrieve
a page in 0.1 ms.
In that case, the
way that we can
use that cache is just before
every time we go to the disk,
we can check and see if the
page that we're trying to load
is in the cache.
And then only if
it's not in the cache
do we need to actually
go to the disks.
And we get a miss on the cache.
We go check the disk to see
if the page is available.
So we can extend the
code in a very simple way
to take advantage of this.
We simply say, we look
up in the cache first,
and then if the page is
null or empty or whatever,
we can't find it in the cache,
then we go ahead and look it up
on the disk.
And then we add that
result to the cache.
So there's a couple
of little details
that we need to work through.
But let's first look at what
the performance of this system
is going to be, or
how this is going
to impact the performance
of what we've been doing.
So if we come over
here, if we think
about what the cost of accessing
a page on this system would be,
well, we're always going to
have to check the cache, right?
That's the first thing we do.
So I'm going to write C for cost
of accessing the cache, where
cost is in this case
going to be expressed
in something like the
number of milliseconds
to do a lookup in the cache,
and then plus the cost
of looking it up on the disk.
But we only have to look up
on the disk some of the time,
right, so there is
some probability
of getting a miss times
the cost of that miss.
OK, so in this case, we said
the cost of going to the cache
was 0.1 ms.
The cost of going to
the disk is 10 ms.
OK, and now what we're
left is to figure out
what the probability
of this miss is.
So if you think about a
system for a little bit,
you might say, well, OK, what
does the system look like?
What's the probability that we
are actually going to get a hit
or miss?
And if what the
applications are doing
is simply generating
random requests
for random pages, which
might be one model of how
the application
behaves, then it doesn't
seem like cache
is going to buy us
very much, right,
because the cache is
going to be a small fraction
of the total size of the disk.
It might be in RAM, so we
might have 100 MB of cache,
and we might have 10
GB of disk, right?
So that means there is a
factor of 100 difference
between these two things.
So if the page
requests are random,
the probability that something
is going to be in the cache
is going to be very low.
It's going to be only, say, 1%.
But it turns out that
almost all applications
have an interesting property
which is commonly referred
to as locality of reference.
What this means is that if you
look at which pages a program
is likely to access
over time, be
these pages of data
or parts of a program,
typically a page that has
been accessed recently
is very likely to
be accessed again.
So a simple example
might be that if you
look at the files that are
being used in a computer system,
usually there is a
small set of files
that a user is working with
at any given point in time.
You're running certain
programs; you're
editing certain documents.
And there's a huge
array of other programs
and files and documents
that are on the system
that you aren't accessing.
And when those active
files are being accessed,
there's a much
higher probability
of getting a hit of looking
at those active files
then there is of going to
any one of the other files.
So even when the difference
between these things
is, say, a factor of 100,
in the case of a Web server,
it might be very
likely that we would
have 90% maybe of the pages
that have been accessed
are already in the cache.
So in that case, sorry, this
probability should be 0.9, 90%.
OK, so suppose that
the probability, sorry,
the probability of a hit is 90%.
The probability of
a miss is then 10%.
OK, so if you look at now
what this sort of formula
evaluates to, we see it's
0.1 plus ten times 0.1.
So, it's 1.1
milliseconds on average,
assuming that we get a
90% hit rate on our cache.
OK, so if you now come
back to this diagram, that
means that the throughput
of the box is one over 1.1,
remember, because throughput
is just one over latency
when we have sort of just
this one module, which
means that now we can
process something like,
so this is something
like, sorry,
this should be one over latency.
But this is in milliseconds.
So this is 0.1, one, sorry, the
number of seconds is 0.0011,
right?
So, one over 0.0011
is about 900.
OK, so we can get about
900 requests per second
that we can process
instead of just 100.
This is approximately equal.
OK, so what we've
managed to do is
increase the throughput
at this stage
by about a factor of nine.
I mean, now you can see
that sort of all three
of these stages are close to
about 1,000 requests a second.
We have increased the
performance of the system
pretty dramatically by
introducing the cache.
And you have to remember
that this cache is only
going to be a good
idea when we are
sure that we have this
locality of reference property.
OK, so if the Web server
is going to a random page,
if the Web server
is sort of asked
to fetch a random
page on every request,
the cache is not going
to be a good choice.
But most of the time Web servers
to have this locality property.
So the last little
detail that we
need to talk about when
we talk about caches,
is the sort of question about
how we deal with page eviction.
So in this diagram here, when
we call add to the cache,
if the cache is already
full of results,
we have to pick something
to replace, right?
So we need what's called a page
removal or page replacement
policy.
OK, so you guys presumably have
seen different page removal
or page replacement
properties in 6.004 before.
I'll just talk about
two very quickly:
a FIFO policy and a LRU policy.
OK, so what FIFO means
is First In First Out.
So it says the
thing to throw out
is the first thing that
we loaded into the cache.
OK, so if I access
a set of pages,
suppose I have a
three element cache
and I access a set of pages,
one, two, three, two, one,
four, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to load this.
I'm going to access
these three pages.
Page 1 will be the first
one that's in my cache.
So when I try and load page
4, I'm going to evict page 1.
OK, that's what's going
to happen in a FIFO system
because one was the first
one that was loaded.
But a least recently
used approach
says instead of evicting
the first thing that
was put into the cache, we want
to evict the last thing that
was read from the cache.
So in this case, if I do one,
two, three, two, one, and then
I get four, the last thing
that was read was three,
and that's what I'll
evict from the cache.
So, if you think about the
intuition behind these two
policies, you sort of realized
that this FIFO approach
has a problem,
which is that it's
sort of contrary to this notion
of locality of reference,
right, because it
doesn't capture anything
about how frequently a
data item is accessed
or when it was last accessed.
It throws the sort of first
access thing out of the cache
even if that first access
thing is read all the time.
LRU sort of captures the
intuition which we want,
which is that something
that's been accessed recently
is likely to be accessed again.
And something that hasn't
been accessed very recently
is less likely to
be accessed again.
So it sort of captures
our intuitive idea
that we want locality
of reference.
So the text talks
much more carefully
about these different
page removal policies.
But anytime you see
anybody talk about a cache,
you should sort of immediately
think to ask the question,
well, what's the page removal
policy that's being used?
OK, so that basically does it
for our discussion of caching
and of performance that
we started last time.
And what we're
going to do now is
move on to the topic
of networking, OK?
So -- So a computer network,
you guys should all be familiar
of what the idea of a
computer network is.
It's some sort of a
connection that connects
multiple computers together.
So why are we interested in
studying a computer network?
What is it that's relevant
about a computer network
for the purposes of this class?
And there's really sort
of two primary reasons.
The first one is that
computer networks are commonly
used as components of systems.
OK, so anytime we are building
a big computer system,
it's very likely it's going
to involve a computer network.
So it's going to
be important for us
to understand what the
properties of computer networks
are, and how computer networks
affect the design of our system
if you want to use them
effectively in our systems.
And computer networks
have a number
of uses in the computer systems.
They do things like allow us
to overcome geographic limits.
So what you guys are all
familiar with the ability
of the Internet to
allow you to check
the score of some
sporting game that's
happening on the other
side of the country,
or to be able to send an e-mail
to your parents back home.
So obviously, being able
to sort of transmit data
over long distances is
clearly a good thing
for many kinds of systems.
They also allow us to
access remote data.
And this is related to the
other thing, to the other one.
But if you have data
that's not on your computer
that you want to
get a hold of, you
may want to contact
your bank and ask them
for your bank balance.
And then finally
they can be used
to physically separate
a client and a server.
So we talked about
the last few lectures,
we spent a while
talking about the fact
that we can use things like
threads and address spaces
in order to provide a sort
of enforced modularity
between modules running
on the same computer.
But there are lots of
situations in which we
want to actually physically
separate the client
and the server, right?
Your bank doesn't
really want you
to be running your copy of
Quicken on their server,
right, because this notion of
enforced modularity we talked
about isn't a perfect
separation between the client
and the server, whereas
putting these things on really
separate machines that are only
connected by this network that
is controlled by this piece of
hardware that's this network
card that sort of talks with the
network, that's a good reason
may be to separate these
things from each other.
And then finally, the
second major reason
why we want to study
networks is simply
that they themselves are
an interesting computer
system, OK?
So we talked in
the first lecture
about some of the interesting
sort of properties
that big computer systems have.
Well, there's not
many computer systems
that are bigger than
the Internet, right?
It's a perfect example of
the giant complex interesting
system with all sorts of
complicated behaviors.
And we'll talk about some of
those complicated behaviors
today as we overview networks.
So the goal of our discussion
of networking in some sense
is going to be to develop
a set of tools that
allow us to have universal
communication between a number
of different clients.
OK.
So what do I mean by that?
Suppose I have some
collection of machines,
which I'll just draw
as little boxes that
are scattered around.
And they are connected together.
What we want to do is to
connect these guys together, OK?
And the network system
that we are going to design
is going to be the
interconnect that allows these
got to talk to each other.
And what we want
this network to be
able to provide at
a very high level
is the ability to do
any-to-any communication.
OK, so if this is
A and this is D,
we want to A to be able to
send a message to D or anybody
else who's in this network.
And that should be true for any
of the pairs that we can find.
And so, in some
sense, what we're
going to do over the course
of the next couple of weeks
is sort of see how we
design this cloud that
sits in between all these
different computers.
If you like, you can sort
of think of this cloud.
Often times, the Internet
is represented as a cloud.
It's just some black box that
you sort of send messages
into with an address.
And on the other
side, the message
pops out at the other end.
So, we're going to
dive into this cloud
and see what happens
inside of it.
So, in order to
start to understand
some of the challenges
of building this cloud,
we are going to start
looking top down.
We're going to look
at the biggest issues
that we have to deal
with, and then we're
going to break up those issues
into some smaller pieces.
So - - OK, so what
are the issues
that sort is immediately
pop out when you first
start thinking about the
properties of a network?
Well, so there's some
technological issues which
have to do with things like
the physical medium over which
you're transmitting messages,
or the properties of the links
over which you're
transmitting them,
the rates at which you can
send data, the lost rate,
the percentage of messages
that get lost by the link
as it's transmitted.
So those are the
kinds of things we
mean by technological concerns.
And so one kind of
technological concern is this,
is sort of the different
kinds of technology
that we might use
for transmission.
And we saw this notion of D
technology over DT before.
It's just this idea
that technology,
just like the technology
in your computer system
has been evolving
dramatically over time.
The technology of networks has
been evolving dramatically.
And we're going to
sort of study some
of the range of
different technologies
that we have to deal with.
There also are a set of limits,
technological, physical,
fundamental limits that are
associated with networks.
So, these are things like
the speed of light, OK?
We simply can't send messages
faster than the speed of light,
right?
These are messages that are
being transmitted [down wire?].
And they propagate
at some speed.
And that's going to be
fundamentally a bottleneck
in the design of
a computer system.
If I have to send
a message from here
to California, that
message isn't going
to get there any sooner
than the amount of time
it takes for light to
travel across the country.
And the amount of
time that it takes
to transmit a message
across the country
is nontrivial in computer time.
It might be a couple
hundred milliseconds.
And that's a long time
as we saw before it
when we have a processor
that connects one
billion instructions a second.
OK, so the other
interesting issue
that's going to come
out about networks
is that networks are a
shared infrastructure, OK?
What that means is that there
are multiple users who are
simultaneously using a network.
You guys, of course, all know
this from using the Internet.
And all the networks that
we study in this class
are basically a
shared infrastructure.
And we'll talk in
a minute about why
the networks are fundamentally
almost always going
to be sort of shared.
They're going to
have to transmit
data for multiple different
users at the same time.
And that's going to present
a number of challenges
about how we ensure that
the network is fair,
that everybody gets
to send their data
when they want to send
data, how we sort of
allow multiple people to
access the same physical wire
at the same point in time.
OK, so what I want to do is
I'll talk about these two things
now in order.
I'm going to start off by
talking about technology.
So -- So the first interesting
technological problem,
which I've already mentioned
is that these networks are
extremely diverse.
They are heterogeneous.
OK, networking technology
has evolved a great deal
in the past 20 years or 30
years since networks first
started being designed.
And that means there is a
huge sort of range of devices
that we might have to
transmit data over.
So let me show you what I mean.
This is just a graph showing
the rate of transmission,
the sort of number
of bits per second
that you can send over
different networking protocols.
And the thing to take
away from this first
is to note that on
the Y axis here,
this is an exponential scale.
So the technology
at the very bottom,
things like early
telephone modems,
could maybe send data
at 10 kb per second,
whereas these sort of high-end
router class devices that
are running the Internet or sort
of very fast desktop Ethernet
kinds of connections
that are coming out today
can send more like,
say, in this case we
have 10 Tb a second, right,
so one times ten to the tenth.
So we are talking about a factor
of ten to the seventh or ten
to the eighth difference
in performance
in terms of the number of bits
that these different kinds
of devices can
actually transmit.
So, that's pretty dramatic.
And that's going to make it
difficult to design computer
systems.
OK, and these
kinds of variations
occur not only at
the sort of number
of bits that we can
send per second,
but also in terms of the
propagation delay of the links,
OK?
So if I have a local
area network that's
connecting two computers
in my office together,
I may be able to transmit
a message from one computer
to the other in an order
of microseconds, OK?
But as we said before,
to send a message
all the way across the
country might take 200 ms.
To send a message
across the Pacific Ocean
by way of the satellite
around the United States
might take a second.
To send a message
to Mars might take
tens of seconds or a minute.
OK, so there's this huge range
in terms of transmission times
that some of these
different links have.
So, fundamentally these
two things, bit rate
and propagation delay
are going to tell us
how long we would expect it to
take for a message to travel
from one place to the other.
So for example,
the amount of time,
so we can think of a
communication link,
if you like, as being a piece of
pipe, which has some width that
is the bit rate.
OK, so the width of the
pipe is the number of bits
that I can cram down this thing.
So, a wider pipe I can
shove more data down it.
But no matter how much data I
can shove down it per second,
there still is some link
to this pipe, right?
And that's the sort of
separation between the sender
and receiver.
And that's bottlenecked,
as we said before,
by the speed of light.
And that's going to
affect how long it
takes for a message to get from,
say, one endpoint to the other.
So if you think
about the total time
to transmit a message
from one guy to the other,
it's going to be
the amount of time
it takes to pack the bits into
the beginning of the pipe,
right, and then
the amount of time
that it takes for all those
bits to come out the other end.
So it's going to be some
combination of the propagation
delay plus the
transmission delay.
The propagation
delay is just going
to be equal to length
divided by, say, for example,
the speed of light.
And we're going to need to
add to that the transmission
delay, which is simply going
to be the number of bits
we have to send divided by the
bit rate, the number of bits
per second.
OK, and so this is the time
to send along one link.
OK, so it's worth remembering
that this time to send
equation, this is only to
send along a single link.
If we have to send more data,
if there are multiple people,
for example, who are waiting
to get access to a link,
that may increase the delay
that it takes to send a message.
Or if we have to relay a
message over multiple hops
and there are some intermediate
node in between each of those
hops, then that
sort of processing
at each intermediate node
may take some additional time
as well.
OK, so if we look
at a graph of some
of the properties
of networks, it's
interesting to sort of
look at the rate of change
of these different technologies.
So this is just showing
what Moore's Law is.
So we saw this before.
Processor speed
doubles every 18 months
according to Moore's Law.
If you look at the size of
the Internet, so the number
of things that we have
to connect together,
well, that's been
doubling every 13 months.
So this has this sort
of exponential behavior
that Moore's Law has as well.
So we are talking about
sort of the number of things
that we have to connect
together is just
growing at this massive rate.
And that's a real
challenge for designing
the kinds of protocols
that we are going to need
to use in these networks.
The other thing that we
see that's been going up
at the same rate or even faster
is the amount of traffic that's
being sent over the Internet.
So more and more people
are sending data.
And again, this
affects the sort of,
this is the challenge
for designing protocols
that are able to scale up and
up and up to these greater
and greater rates.
The largest link capacity
in the past few years
has actually started to go up as
fast as double once every seven
months.
So this is the size of
the largest pipe that's
on the Internet, say, connecting
lots of these big service
providers on the
Internet together.
And this is just been getting
larger and larger and larger
as well.
And so that's,
again, means in order
to exploit all this
additional link capacity,
we need faster computers.
And the rate of
change of technology
is just extremely high.
Interestingly enough,
of course, as we
said before, the speed
of light never changes.
So this is a
fundamental constraint
that we're always going
to have to deal with when
we are building these things.
That is also the case
that if you look at,
there's another number
that you can look at.
And in the context
of the Internet,
this number is, this is
bits per second per dollar.
OK, so what does that mean?
This is the amount
of money that it
costs to, for example,
send one bit per second
over the Internet.
And this number just has not
been scaling up very fast.
If you look at
this, it's a factor
of ten cheaper today
than it was in 1980
to send the same amount
of data per second out
over the Internet.
So, why is that?
That seems strange, right?
I mean, if you look at the
fundamental technology,
the technology itself
has gotten much faster.
If you look at the
Ethernet network
that you might have in
your home or your office,
this thing has
gotten, in 1980 you
might have had one
megabit a second
that you could transmit
over this Ethernet.
You can now, for $100
go to Best Buy and buy
something that can
transmit a gigabit a second
over an Ethernet.
OK, so we are talking about
a huge scale up in technology
in terms of the performance
of the networks.
The issue here is that
there is a human cost that's
associated with sending
data out over the Internet.
And if I want to send data
from here to California,
there's a physical wire that
that data has to transfer over,
right?
And somebody owns that wire.
And it cost somebody
a lot of money
to cut the holes in the
ground where that wire runs
and to knock holes
through buildings
and to get rights
from all the cities
that that wire runs through
to dig holes in their roads,
right?
So, there is some
very large human cost
associated with setting up
these sort of very wide area
internets.
And you see the
same kind of thing
not just in wire but
in wireless technology
with wireless companies
paying huge amounts of money
for access to the rights
to use a particular part
of the wireless spectrum.
So this is these bits
per second per dollar
is growing slowly, OK, and the
reason for that is human costs.
OK, and what this
argues for, what
this suggests that
we are going to need
to do when we are
building these internets
or building these
large networks is
to share these network links.
So, if every time we added
a new host to the network,
we had to run a wire
that connected it
to every other host
in the network.
Obviously, that would
be hugely expensive,
so we want to avoid that.
And so, we are going
to end up because
of these costs of physically
running the wires having
to share network connections.
And that brings us to
sort of the next topic
that I want to talk about,
which is this topic of sharing.
OK, so just that
everybody is clear,
this notion of having
pair-wise links,
a connection from every
host every other host
is just not practical.
So suppose I have them
set of nodes like this,
if I want to connect
all of them together
by their own set of
independent wires,
I don't know if I got
all of them there,
but then the cost is going
to be, if I have N hosts,
the cost is going to
be N squared wires.
OK, and that is just
too expensive, right?
If you have a
million hosts, you're
going to have a trillion wires.
So we don't want to be
building anything that has
a trillion components in it.
It's going to be really,
really expensive to deploy.
So what we end up
doing is multiplexing.
OK, so what do I mean by that?
I mean this notion
of sharing links.
So let's look at
a very simplified
kind of an architecture for
something like the Internet.
So suppose I have two hosts, two
nodes, two computers, A and B
that I want to be able
to communicate over
a network to some other
pair of nodes, C and D.
OK, well in a multiplex
network, what we're going to do
is we're going to have a
set of these boxes that
are going to connect
these nodes together.
So I just sort of shown one
possible network topology.
But with these boxes are, they
are sometimes called switches.
And they are the
connection points
that are scattered
in various locations
around the Internet
that transfer data
from one location to the other.
So in your home, you may
well have what's sometimes
called a wireless router.
That's the thing that
transfers data from the air
onto a wire network.
You may have a box
from your cable company
that transfers data from
your home out over the cable.
And then the cable
company itself
has a box that transfers
data to some other service
provider, which may be transfers
data across the country, which
transfers data into the home of
whoever you're trying to send,
or the business
of whoever you're
trying to send a message to.
So you have this set of what
we are calling switches here
that connect all these
various hosts together.
And these hosts clearly,
there are connections here
that are sharing data.
So if I look at this link here,
if both A and B are trying
to send data to
C, clearly there's
going to be some data for both
A and B traveling on this wire.
And so, what we end up
with is, sorry, so there
is a set of issues that
are brought up by the fact
that we are sharing this
data, and that we have
this kind of switched
infrastructure
which we are running
data around in.
So the first issue
that we need to talk
about that obviously comes
up is this notion of routing.
OK, so when you see
a graph like this
and you ask the
question, well, OK,
how does A get its data to C?
We have to pick
some route which A
is going to take
along this path,
through this network
in order to get to C.
And, there are a couple of
different alternatives, right?
So, any time you're
sending a message,
there has to be something that
plans out how that route is
going to be transmitted.
And commonly what
happens is that each one
of these intermediate
points along the network
has some table which says how
to get to every other location
within the network.
And we'll talk about
how those tables work,
how these tables that talk about
where to forward your messages
to work.
But when a node has multiple
sort of possible locations
where it can send data out
to, typically that node
is called a router.
OK, so if you hear
the term router,
just think of it as one of
these switch things that
gets to make a decision about
where some kind of traffic
is going to be sent to.
OK, so now what we
need to do in order
to think a little bit more
about how these switches work
is to resolve the issue of
how we multiplex traffic
over one of these links.
So we said there may be
traffic for both A and B
running on this
link going into D.
Well, so how are we going
to interleave the traffic
from A and B in order
to make this work?
And there are two techniques.
We call this technique
for interleaving data,
we call it switching
or multiplexing.
And we're going to talk about
two techniques for switching.
We're going to talk
about circuit switching.
And we'll talk about
packet switching.
So circuit switching
is pretty easy
to understand at
an intuitive level.
The idea with the
circuit switch is
that we want to set up
some reserved channel that
is the communication channel
between two endpoints,
say for example, A and C.
So, a simple way if you want to
think about circuit switching
is to think about the way that
phone networks used to work.
So you may have seen these old
movies where the operator would
plug wires into a switchboard.
What an operator is doing
there is establishing
a physical circuit, a
physical wire that connects
two endpoints together.
OK, so that's circuit switching.
Each operator has a
bunch of lines coming in
and a bunch of lines coming out.
Somebody connects
to the operator
and says I want
to talk to line A.
And the operator establishes
the physical connection.
So, of course we don't
use that technology
for doing circuit
switching anymore,
but this notion of
circuit switching
is still used in the
telephone system.
And the way that a common
digital telephone system
might work is as follows.
So the idea is that suppose I
have some set of nodes A, B,
and C, all of which want to send
their data out over some line.
So they are connecting
up to some switch.
And they want us their
data out over this switch,
out over this wire that is on
the other side of this switch.
OK, so what this kind of
switching that we are going
to talk about does, which is
commonly called TDM for Time
Division Multiplexing --
is to give each
one of these nodes,
A, B, and C, a
little unit of time
in which only its traffic is
being transmitted on this wire.
So if you think of
this wire as having
one additional
piece of information
put on at each unit of time, and
this is the wire stretching out
away from the host so
that this is sort of time
is going this way as the signal
propagates down the wire.
And if you were to look at all
the different messages that
are on the wire, what you see
is sort of a repeating pattern
of time intervals.
And each of these time
intervals would be carved up
into a number of slots.
OK, and each slot is allocated
to exactly one of these nodes.
And each node gets the
same slot and each one
of these larger intervals.
OK, so you'd see a pattern
like A's traffic, B's traffic,
C's traffic, and so on.
And then in the next
interval we would
have A's traffic, B's traffic,
and C's traffic again.
So there would be
this repeating pattern
where each node is associated
to the same slot in every one
of these intervals, OK?
And we call the data
that, say, for example, A
puts into a slot a frame.
The frame is sort
of the set of data
that is allocated to a node.
And, so this is
basically the way
that circuit switching works.
And it's almost exactly the
way that the phone network
works now.
So a phone network
carves up the wire
into a bunch of these
little slots where
each conversation is allocated
one of these sort of frames
in each interval.
So in a typical phone network,
a frame might be eight bits.
And there might be
these intervals.
There might be 8,000
of them per second.
OK, so we have 8,000
intervals per second.
OK, and so what that means is
that if each frame is eight
bits and there is
8,000 intervals,
each sender can send
64,000 bits per second.
And, it turns out that
64,000 bits per second
is about enough to be
able to encode voice
at a sort of acceptable
level for people.
So we can talk about the
capacity of this channel
by basically looking
at the number of frames
that are in one interval.
So if we say there are N
max frames in one interval,
then that specifies the
number of conversations
that we can simultaneously
maintain on this wire.
OK, so the behavior of one of
these circuit-switched systems
is as follows: everybody
who's having a conversation
has bandwidth allocated to
them, and has a frame allocated
to them in every interval.
So, up to N max conversations
can be held simultaneously
and there's no problem.
But as soon as we
get to the N max
plus first guy tries
to initiate a call,
the network will simply refuse
to accept that connection
because there's no slot
available for this guy
to do his communication.
And the last little detail about
how these circuit switches work
is how do we actually
establish a connection
in the first place?
And we need some protocol
for actually resorting
to a slot for a
particular connection
between a pair of endpoints.
And so typically
what you will do
is reserve some frame
or set of frames
to carry information that's
used to configure the connection
between the endpoints.
So, A can request that
an interval be assigned
to its connection
between C, and then it
will be by communicating
during a special frame.
OK, so that's circuit switching.
But, circuit switching
has a problem.
And we're going to need to
introduce this notion of packet
switching to deal with it.
OK, so the reason that circuit
switching has a problem
is as follows: because although
circuit switching works
great for voice where every
conversation is essentially
a continuous stream of audio
that can always be encoded
at about 64 kb per second,
Internet traffic just
doesn't work like that, right?
People who are communicating
on the Internet
can have very variable demands
for the amount of traffic
that they want to send.
And even taken as an aggregate,
taking all the people who
are, say, for example at the
community of MIT over time,
there still is a
lot of variation
in the network demand.
So this is just a plot over the
course of the day with samples
taken every five minutes
of the amount of traffic
that was being sent out
of one of MIT's labs.
OK, and so you don't need
to worry too much about what
these different lines show.
But the point is that there
are these periodic spikes.
And these spikes represent
spikes of traffic
demand a different
machines on the network.
So you can see that at any
given point in time, there
can be anywhere
from, at its lowest,
these numbers are about 40 Mb
per second to numbers as high
as 100 Mb a second.
So there's a lot of variation
in the demand at MIT's network.
Here's another way of
looking at the same traffic.
This is an interesting graph.
This is showing the
amount of traffic
that different protocols use.
This is a real graph by the way.
This is showing the
amount of traffic
that is transmitted over MIT's
network for different types
of protocols.
And what you see here is that
it's really pretty amazing.
You see that Kazaa, this
file trading network,
is using up a vast majority of
the traffic that we send out
of MIT.
But besides that, there's
another interesting point
which is that noticed during the
months of October and November,
the two leftmost
lines here, we are
sending a lot more traffic than
during the month of December.
So, if you were at
MIT and are trying
to plan how much traffic you
expected to be transmitted
during a month,
this makes it hard
because there was a 50% drop
in the amount of traffic
from one month on
this Kazaa network.
So we need to introduce
this notion of packet
switching to deal with this
problem of unpredictable rates.
OK, so in many kinds
of data networks,
it's simply not
possible to predict
exactly how much traffic
you're going to need
to send at any point in time.
And so the idea is
to use something
called asynchronous multiplexing
instead of time division
multiplexing.
And the idea is as follows.
Suppose we have our three nodes,
A, B, and C all transmitting
data through some
switch out over a wire
just like we did before.
If you look at
the traffic that's
being transmitted on this
wire, what you'll see
is that it's not
necessarily going
to have the same regular
pattern that we had before.
The idea is that
any node is allowed
to try and start talking on this
wire any time that it wants.
It's asynchronous.
It's not timed.
There's no regular slots when
nodes are required to transmit.
So this might be traffic for A.
This might be traffic for A.
This might be traffic
for B, A, A, and C.
OK, so what this
suggests, and noticed
that these packages of data
that are being transmitted
are of different sizes.
Typically these
are called packets.
And that's what this
is packet switching
because we are sending the full
packages of information that
are of a variable size as
opposed to these fixed size
frames that we were
transmitting before.
And notice that there is no
requirement that A transmitted
any specific time.
A is allowed to try and
transmit as much as it wants.
But this does
introduce a complexity
because it makes it hard
to plan for the capacity
of the network.
So suppose that
each of A, B, and C
have a 1 Mb per second link, and
suppose that this link is also
1 Mb per second.
Now, clearly if A, B, and C
are rarely sending any traffic,
then everybody
may be able to get
all its data onto the network.
But if A, B, and C
all decide that they
want to send at the same
time at 1 Mb per second,
then there's going to be
a problem because they're
going to be trying to send
more data over this link them
the link has capacity for.
And so what that
immediately suggests
is that in these boxes, in
these packet switch networks,
there is some kind of a queue.
OK, so we're doing queuing
within the network.
But it also, so you
might ask the question,
why don't network designers
design these packet switch
networks so that you
never have a link that's
connecting multiple
endpoints together
that doesn't have sufficient
capacity to transmit all
of the information from all
of the endpoints that may
be transmitting data over it?
But if you think about
this for a second,
that's going to be
a really bad idea.
So suppose we are
on the Internet.
And suppose that I am
designing simple website.
I want to set up a website
for students of 6.033.
If I needed to make sure
that that website had
sufficient bandwidth that
could support connections
from everybody who
is on the Internet
just in case everybody who's on
the Internet decided to access
that website at
exactly the same time,
I would be in big
trouble, right,
because I would have to
have hundreds of terabits
of bandwidth available
to me in order
to be able to support that.
So clearly I'm not
going to do that.
Instead, what I'm going to do
as a network designer is simply
try and ensure that most
of the time my network has
enough bandwidth
available for the users
were going to be accessing it.
But some of the time,
there may not be.
I may sort of under-provision
the network, may not
provide enough resources.
And so during those times
when the network has
more data that's trying
to be sent over it than it
could possibly send, we
call those congestion times.
And when a network is subject
to long periods of congestion,
these queues that are sitting
in the network may fill up.
So these queues are
some fixed size.
They are stored typically
in RAM on a device,
and they can over-fill.
And when they over-fill, we
have to do something about it.
OK, so this problem of
congestion in networks
leads to all sorts of kind
of interesting trade-offs
in the design of these
packet switch networks.
And typically the bottom
line is basically,
and we'll talk about
this in much more detail,
but the bottom line is
typically these packet
switch networks have to be able
to drop data some of the time.
If a queue over-fills,
the network
has no choice but to refuse
to transmit data for somebody.
But because these packet
switch networks are composed
of multiple routers
along the way,
it may be that the data
is actually dropped deep
in the network by some router
not when I first try and send
the data, but five hops down the
line the data may be dropped.
And so these kinds
of things complicate
the design of these systems.
Queuing means there's
variable delay.
OK, and congestion means
there may be data that's lost.
And to deal with lost, we may
have to retransmit packets.
And so this gets the sort
of fundamental notion
that's going to come up in the
design of these packet switch
networks, and that's
that the extraction
that these packet
switch networks provides
is so-called best
effort networking.
And that means at
the lowest level,
these networks don't
guarantee that the data
that you send over them
will actually be delivered.
All they say is
the network is sort
of promising that it
will try hard to get
the data to be delivered.
But you as a user,
the applications that
are using this run
network interface
need to understand that
this variable delay,
they need to
understand that there's
congestion that can
happen which means
that packets can be dropped.
Congestion also means
that typically packets
may be retransmitted.
And so that means
that all of your data
may not arrive at the other end.
And so this is the best
effort network abstraction,
and we're going to talk about
these kinds of best effort
network abstractions exclusively
for the next several weeks
as opposed to these
circuit switch networks.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to see how we can build
up a set of software that
runs on top of these best
effort networks that allows us
to provide things
like, for example,
some reasonable guarantee of
reliable delivery, that data
won't be lost as data is
transmitted over the network.
So we will see how
we build up layers
on top of this
best effort network
stack that allow us to provide
certain guarantees to the user.
So that's it for today, and
tomorrow we will talk about,
starting Monday we will
talk about the link layer
interface for these things.
Don't forget about the exam.